patty-cake fired up a hit my hands I
might at this time hey everybody it's
Charlie so everybody's still wondering
about what's going on with iron fist and
Luke Cage now that Netflix and Marvel
have cancelled their TV series there
have been separate conspiracy theories
about Netflix doing a Heroes for Hire TV
show and then separate one about Disney
doing one on their streaming service
like they had something to do with the
deal falling through for future seasons
so that they could swipe the characters
and just put them on their streaming
service the problem is is that there are
a couple of things that are preventing
Netflix from doing a Heroes for Hire TV
show and from Disney separately doing it
on their streaming service so I'll
explain what's going on but there's a
new round of that spider-man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a mark
or related comment on the video it's
important to remember that Marvel and
Netflix have both separately openly
talked about how the characters will
continue even though their shows will
not so Netflix does have plans for those
two characters but because of some new
evidence I don't think that those future
plans have anything to do with doing a
separate spin-off Heroes for Hire TV
show first bit of evidence sharply
rising costs above the line costs like
actors fees and just the cost of
actually making the shows in a rapidly
declining interest in the series over
time Netflix has a big problem with the
way it structures its contracts so early
on when they bought the rights to do
these Marvel TV shows it was for for the
characters and the defenders team-up
they bought a block of about 60 episodes
some of the shows like daredevil Luke
Cage Jessica Jones got nominated for
awards but by the time they got to their
big defenders team-up which was supposed
to be their big Avengers level event
that we've been building towards since
they started daredevil season 1 interest
has started to flatline in all the
series the reason why they canceled
plans for defenders season 2 like why
you haven't heard about that is because
interest in that was so low so we didn't
justify another season but individually
some of the TV shows which were a little
bit cheaper than defenders did actually
still have a pretty high interest level
Netflix bought another block of about 70
plus episodes that's where you got your
daredevil season 2 your Luke Cage season
2 iron fist
season two Jessica Jones season two
you're Punisher spinoff series so at the
time Netflix still felt like interest
level was high enough to justify them
buying this giant block of episodes and
they get a discount from Marvel on their
licensing fees when they buy in bulk
like that the other bad thing about
their contracts and all this is that
because they don't lock the actors down
for like a five-year contract like a
typical network does the actors get paid
way more money with each new season
meaning it costs Netflix way more money
to produce the episodes before they ever
start rolling the cameras so in order to
justify paying those rising costs with
each new season the show just has to be
a big hit with their viewers and because
it's digital they can measure everything
about the way people watch how long they
watch which parts of episodes they skid
through which episodes they rewatched
the most it's just a much more accurate
way of measuring interest level and
shows so because Netflix doesn't
officially report numbers typically what
outside agencies do to measure their
sort of Nielsen ratings of it all is use
online conversation like on Ryan
interest level as a way of determining
how many people at any given time are
talking about a particular show so
business week and another research
agency did a graphs of interest level in
all the Marvel Netflix shows over the
past couple of years starting with
season 1 going through all the current
seasons and you can see right here
daredevil for instance is probably one
of their most popular ones interest
level super high for season one still
pretty high for season two then
obviously we had to wait for forever to
get season 3 but even though interest
level doesn't seem quite as high this is
really only like the first couple of
days because it literally just dropped
last week so this graph will probably go
up just a little bit higher than come
back down you look at Luke Cage for
instance it has a crazy high spike in
interest for season ones premiere
remember how they said that they crash
the Netflix servers when season 1
premiere everybody wanted to find out
what it was gonna be like this is what
happened when we got to season 2 so even
though they turned that around within a
year of Luke Cage season 1 it was only
about 25% as popular as daredevil season
2 so just rapidly declining interest
you've been asking about Jessica Jones
will that be the next series that they
canceled I do think looking at this
graph although there is pretty high
interest
compared to Luke Cage for Jessica Jones
season two
they've already shot Jessica Jones
season three if its viewership is at
least as high as season two was I think
that if they keep the budget down it has
a good shot of being renewed Punisher is
still a bit of a question mark because
there's not enough data to analyze
because this is all about comparing
season to viewership compared to season
one so a broader interest in those two
characters is solo it doesn't really
make sense for Netflix to pay a ton of
extra money to renew both the outers
contracts and pay for this big team-up
show which would probably be twice as
expensive as either one of the
individual shows remember when Danny
Rand came to visit Luke Cage that
episode was probably way more expensive
if they were to do a team-up show they
would have to do it just like when Iron
Fist guest-starred during Luke Cage
season two so already that's twice as
expensive so unless that was going to be
the most popular show that Netflix had
ever done it just wouldn't justify them
paying the extra money for it but
because they have the rights to the
characters they can keep using Luke Cage
and iron fist all they want they can
make deals with both of those actors to
cameo on the other Netflix series like
daredevil season 4 which I do think is a
pretty good shot for renewal for all of
you asking about the conspiracy theories
about Disney trying to hoard them for
their streaming service like why don't
they just do Luke Cage season 3 on the
disney streaming service keep in mind
the idea of how much it cost to produce
in general interest level and the idea
that Disney has already confirmed
they're doing big Game of Thrones level
Avengers spin-off TV shows with Tom
Hiddleston Scarlet Witch there's a rumor
about a Nick Fury TV show and eventually
they'll probably try to do a black
panther spin-off TV show on their
streaming service so if you're Disney
and you have the choice to spend a
hundred million dollars on say like a
black panther TV show would you rather
spend that money on a Luke Cage iron
fist TV show when most people weren't
really big fans of iron fist
it just feels like Disney is gonna put
its money behind its a player's the
Avengers content and that's what it'll
go with for its streaming service the
only way that they'd be able to do a
Luke Cage season 3 for instance like
just literally take everything slap a
Disney logo on it and air it on their
streaming service is if Netflix just
gave them that property back because
Netflix bought and paid
for that character so as they originated
it it still lies with them and unless
they give them a whole bunch of money I
don't think that Netflix would give that
up because they'll say you know what
we're just gonna put these characters on
our daredevil show people get really
excited about their cameo but hopefully
that explains why Netflix is probably
not gonna do a Heroes for Hire spin-off
TV show and why Disney probably won't
just steal all those characters for it's
streaming service that doesn't mean the
Disney can't do that it just means that
a lot of money has to change hands
before they did something like that it
like I said if they've already got all
these Avengers characters that are
getting TV shows a big Star Wars game of
Thrones level TV show then it doesn't
make a lot of sense for them to pay a
bunch of extra money for these c-list
characters unless they were also going
to get daredevil and all the other big
characters too and it seems like for now
daredevil and Punisher are staying put
on Netflix I'll do more videos about
those New Avengers TV shows once we get
more information about that and of
course I'll do episode videos when they
premiere but I don't think any of those
are gonna premiere till 2020 so it's
still gonna be a long ways off so no
worries I'll name a new giveaway winner
when I post new marble click here for
that new Iron Man Avengers 4 teaser and
click here to learn more about what's
going on with the cancellation thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight